I miss the desert
I miss the sea
and I miss waking up every morning
wondering what wonderful Adventure
the new day will bring to us
those days have come and gone Perhaps Perhaps not
I don't believe in magic
but a few times in my life
I've seen things I can't explain
I've come to believe it's
not so much what you believe
how hard you believe
thank you
Who is this man. I'm her godfather.
Get back
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will be my
Indiana Jones in the dial of Destiny trailer video
there's a whole bunch of Easter eggs here for all
the other Indiana Jones movies so we'll break it
all down if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos also
a big reminder lucasfilm is also developing an
Indiana Jones TV show I don't know if it's meant
to be a continuation of the young Indiana Jones
Adventures from back in the day back in the 90s
like if it'll be another very young version of
Indiana Jones much earlier in his career or if
it'll be something completely different I expect
them to make more announcements about that after
the movie comes out next year but as you could
tell it jumps all over the timeline because
you see a young version of him de-aged Harrison
Ford even went on to say that yes there is some
de-aging during the film there are some flashbacks
but it doesn't suck like literally they said it
doesn't suck and it actually looks like they
have upgraded their de-aging technology since
the Mandalorian season 2 when they did the D aged
version of Luke Skywalker using their current then
deep fake technology like they got in a big big
upgrade but the actual title itself probably one
of the most important things the dial of death
Destiny supposedly this is going to be a time
travel movie in the dial of Destiny will be them
going back in time with the main villain in the
film played by Maz Mickelson trying to alter the
destiny of the Nazis I'll explain what's going on
with his character but like that's the whole idea
the dial of Destiny is like literally a Time dial
metaphor for time travel itself big coincidence
that the Marvel movies were dealing with a lot
of time Travel Kang the Conqueror Ant-Man of
the Wasp Quantumania trailer that just dropped
now we're doing time travel inside the Indiana
Jones Universe. Harrison Ford has made it sound
like this is going to be the final Indiana Jones
movie that he's ever going to do and after this
lucasfilm has said that they don't plan on
recasting Indiana Jones ever so like this is
supposedly the final Indiana Jones movie ever
for real this time technically they said that
after the fourth film but I think we can pretend
like the fourth film never existed they released
some pictures if you zoom in enhanced you can see
on his finger he's still wearing his wedding band
just continuing the idea that he got married to
Marion at the end of the last movie so nothing's
changed about that I don't know if she's gonna be
be in this movie though given everything that's
happened with Shia LaBeouf in real life in the
last several years I'm also expecting that his
son will not reappear during the movie as well
James Mangold directed this I have a lot of
faith in him he directed The Logan movie which is
probably one of the best Marvel movies of all time
just happened to be made by Fox instead of Marvel
there's a bunch of returning characters from other
movies in the franchise I'll explain them and
the new characters as well starting with the
main villain Mass Mickelson who's playing Jurgen
voller a former Nazi who was given clemency after
World War II and is developing rockets for the
United States through the 1960s the present day of
the movie takes place in the 1960s the last movie
Kingdom of the Crystal Skull was in the 1950s like
we've jumped forward a decade he's meant to be a
long time Nemesis of Indiana Jones they went up
against each other during World War II these are
flashbacks of him during that period where you see
the Nazis all around him the whole idea is that
he wants to use the dial of Destiny to go back
in time and change the destiny of the Nazis Boyd
Holbrook is playing claber he's also one of the
villains he's one of the lap dogs of vol character
Toby Jones is playing basil one of Indiana Jones's
companions during the film kind of like Salah was
Phoebe Waller bridge is playing a character called
Helena who's meant to be his goddaughter and I
believe that she's meant to be the actual daughter
of Marcus Brody explaining their close connection
the Apple doesn't fall far from the tree it seems
like her character is also interested in history
the same way that Marcus Brody was this is Mason
a US government agent who's following Indiana
Jones through this adventure who eventually
probably winds up helping him against the Nazis
there's a quick blink and you'll miss it Antonio
Banderas Cameo seen in the trailer he said he's
playing one of Indiana Jones long time allies
but his role in the film is relatively small and
obviously one of the biggest returning characters
is Salah who tells Indiana Jones it's time for
another adventure even though he doesn't want
to believe it there was a picture that kehui
Kwan posted of him with Harrison Ford of them
reuniting after many many years because he hadn't
seen him since the events of Temple of Doom when
he was a young child he said that he doesn't have
a cameo in this film that was something that was
completely different like separate from the actual
making of the movie he could be misleading us but
I'm not expecting an adult Short Round to show up
during the film The Trailer begins with Indiana
Jones and Helena being chased through the streets
on this vehicle we hear Solo's voice over I miss
the desert I miss the sea I miss waking up every
morning wondering what wonderful Adventure a new
day will bring to us this is him walking
across the street in downtown Manhattan
when Salah mentions the sea you see a couple of
divers underwater in gear from the 1960s we see
the older Indiana Jones inside his classroom
teaching there's a little Death Star Easter
egg in the background here there's a couple Star
Wars Easter eggs inside the trailer you probably
spotted my favorite one is them in the submarine
traveling underwater and it looks just like the
Millennium Falcon my guess is that in the context
of the film this artifact on the board here is the
actual dial of Destiny or connected to the dial
of Destiny itself because in the previous Indiana
Jones movies usually his lecture has something to
do with the actual plot of the movie itself we do
not follow maps to Buried Treasure and X never
ever ever marks this spot ten x marks the spot
he's with Helena here but when they're walking
past the boulder obviously the boulder is another
reference to the Boulder and Raiders of the Lost
Ark the exploding Nazi castle that we see is meant
to be a flashback I believe this is connected to
the opening scene in the movie that stuff is meant
to take place in actual World War II flashbacks
that's what this scene is here where you see him
de-age that's meant to be from the opening scene
of the movie the young Indiana Jones winds up
escaping catching This Plane all the train action
scenes that you see in the trailer probably going
to be a call back to the Last Crusade train
action scene we get another shot inside his
school all these rows of artifacts are just meant
to show you all the different Adventures he's had
in the time that we haven't seen him like off the
screen he's gotten much older had Many Adventures
over the years it's also a bit of a reference to
the government's Warehouse with all the artifacts
boxed up as he and Helena continue exploring
this particular cave here in this scene he starts
talking about how he didn't believe and match
magic before it probably addressing the more
Supernatural aspects of the dial of Destiny during
the movie as you could probably tell this scene
is another de-aged version of Indiana Jones it's
not clear when this is happening during the movie
but this is probably connected to his adventures
fighting voller when they were much younger this
seems like the actual dial of Destiny itself like
the actual Macguffin which they used to travel
back in time what's happening in this Giant action
scene with the parade in him on Horseback is that
they're actually in the middle of celebrating the
1969 Apollo moon landing there's a couple jokes
about him using the whip in the guns which is a
call back to Raiders the Lost Ark foreign get back
there's another reference to the Raiders of the
Lost Arc Boulder scene and it sounds like because
of the whole time travel MacGuffin the whole plot
of the movie they will be visiting or revisiting
aspects of different movies previously in the
franchise the way James Mangold talked about it
they're not changing Canon or anything like that
so I'm just expecting light references to some
of the big moments in the previous movies they
released another big story based trailer early
next year which will give us what the actual plot
is like what Indiana Jones is actually trying to
prevent during the movie although we have a pretty
broad idea prevent Mass Mickelson's character from
completely changing history so that the Nazis wind
up winning in the way James mangle talked about
it even though it is meant to be the last movie
in the trilogy they aren't killing off Indiana
Jones in a really big way or at least he made it
sound like they weren't killing him off they'll
give him some kind of version of a happy ending
that Indiana Jones the character would want for
himself so you can post all your theories about
how you think they're going to end Indiana Jones's
story Willie dies some epic Heroes death or will
he die like his father played by Sean Connery of
old age like really just can't continue living
on after the adventures in this movie it'll be
really interesting to see if he has any kind of
involvement with the Indiana Jones TV show or
offer some kind of intro narration during the
first episode but I don't expect him to have
a lot of involvement with that TV show like he
didn't have a whole lot of involvement with the
young Indiana Jones Adventures when George
Lucas started doing that back in the 90s so
it'll probably be similar with the new series
if he spotted any of the big Easter eggs or
references in the trailer that I didn't talk about
in the video just write them Below in the comments
or if you have big questions about what's going
on in the film like I said I'm expecting to get
some more announcements about that new Indiana
Jones TV show when the movie actually comes out
next year so that won't be for a while because
it's Brazil Comic Con CCXP this week there were
a whole bunch of trailers Marvel had a big
trailer Fest click here for my Guardians of
the Galaxy 3 video and click here for that new
Ant-Man and the Wasp Quantumania trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!